enjoy Eric this is gonna be an expose
into you an investigation a
peregrination into your mind I don't
care too much I care but I but not for
this about your idea I don't care too
much about your ideas for this I care
about your thought process how did you
come up with your ideas if it isn't
already first of all good to be with you
sir
thank you thank you I appreciate that
we'll start broadly okay you have quite
a few projects you have your work for
Peter Thiel I see and you have your
podcast you have your husband your
father you have geometric unity which
you work on so that's five that I can
count does that exhaust it are there
more does it stretch you thin well I
mean there's also the gauge theory and
economics project which I'm very keen to
push through I'm very focused on making
sure that my brother's work on
senescence telomeres and antagonistic
pleiotropy is understood recognized and
its implications chased down there are
some avenues for immigration reform
trying to understand why it is that this
important economic topic is deranged
because it has to do with units of labor
rather than units of capital
yeah there are a number of different
projects but they all sort of seek to
try to make sure that humanity has a
future and that we don't tear ourselves
apart in the present trying to construct
false utopias and that we don't find
ourselves limited by what we've already
achieved in a way where we forsake our
ability to achieve in the future by
actually deranging ourselves in a false
hope of a kind of utopian present which
can can't possibly obtain do you ever
feel like it's too many projects or do
you have one day for one project it's a
chaotic well honestly to be blunt about
it that's not really where I feel like
the problem is the problem is is that I
live in a world that I I have a very
strong impression that people are
generically crazy and in a world in
which I take people to be generically
crazy that is that there's they're
simply humans and computing machines
that have been fed lots of terrible
information on a daily basis of a few
centralized sources and so the biggest
problem is there aren't enough people to
work on the projects that matter because
everyone is constantly distracted and
distractible by projects that do not and
that the the incentive structures can't
be put towards things that must be done
there in fact structured almost so that
the things that can that must be done
cannot be done and I think that's the
biggest problem so that mean leaves me
working alone on too many things
speaking of working alone you have a
wife who's er collaborator at least in
the Economics Department when did you
get married in 1996 how old were you
about 30
how did you know she was the right one
or do you not believe in the right one
well I have different theories about
this I believe that you meet the right
one every three years on average that
there there isn't what one right person
for each one of us but there's a very
small subset of people who can be the
right one and you know I would say that
when you meet and
Indian Jewish super mind who's
incredibly gorgeous and has a huge heart
who takes your breath away and makes you
laugh it's pretty hard to resist so
there aren't so many people like Pia
Milani he's just truly amazing human
being on just about every axis I mean I
sometimes feel bad when people say you
have to compromise on various things and
outside of a tiny number of areas I feel
like there was no compromise with her at
all just one person had everything in
beyond BIA and and I just I think I
guess I've enjoyed my time talking being
and traveling with Pia more than I ever
imagined I could enjoy another community
now you said enjoy do you still enjoy
that is to say I know that after some
time marriages don't have the same zeal
or spark but they did in the beginning
do you feel like you've managed to
maintain it or it's increased or
decreased or it's changed it's a deeper
level as meaningful that is not
encapsulated by why well you're talking
you're talking to the wrong guy I mean
I'm just I'm I'm still I guess I would
if you told me I had 10 years on a sand
bar with enough coconuts and fish to get
by with Pia I would say that that would
be a complete intellectual diet I could
spend my time talking thinking
theorizing arguing and it's very weird
if I just think about my family my wife
and our two kids those would be probably
the three people that any one of whom
would be a complete a relatively
complete life in terms of just being so
to people and and being fascinated by
their minds and and appreciative of the
differences between us all my family is
exactly the people that I find most
fascinating and most fulfilling to talk
how do you know you were ready to have
kids that wasn't nobody is was it a
surprise
or you just decided to jump in
voluntarily um you know when I when I
met my wife I probably told her that I
really didn't need to have children and
I think she really needed to have kids
and you know kids are a very strange
undertaking in that there are few
features we don't appreciate first of
all they have the strange feature that
they are the most fascinating things
that are absolutely not fascinating by
fascinating to talk about so like if I
start to tell you about what my kid did
today your eyes will glaze over but to
me it's the most fast figured the wrong
so it divides us in a very strange way
because we're so asymmetrically attached
to our own children another feature that
I think is really interesting is that if
my kids didn't absolutely fascinate me
it would be the greatest time sink in
the world but if you have great kids
there's nothing better you can do with
your life so it's really it's important
to love your children I think Jordan
Peterson has one of his basic rules for
life is don't let your children become
anything that don't let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them or
something like that I just I guess I
feel like it's it's about the biggest
time sink imaginable
so it's astounding that anything can pay
for itself given the given the demands
and yet child rearing I would absolutely
recommend it to anyone if you really
love your kids
you managed at least in my estimation to
stay productive I think you're extremely
productive you might not consider
yourself to be some people think on
counter product well
either way there's a word productive in
there you're doing something do you do
you consider yourself to be productive
and do you take nootropics what does
your schedule look like how do you
maintain yes I have no schedule I have a
terrible sleep schedule I don't take no
tropics I don't sell optimize in any of
the sort of Tim Ferriss style ways why
not well it's a very weird question or
ways in which I think like I really left
this planet when I started making
theoretical physics very seriously and I
don't exactly know what those words mean
but it's a sort of a dissociative brain
state where you don't really think about
this as the plane of existence you think
about trying to commune with something
else
it means you sort of lose track of the
here in the now the practical the
instance of something you know if I have
a coffee mug do I see this as the
Platonic essence of all coffee mugs or
do I see it as the particular coffee mug
that I'm holding that as a chip on one
side you know I think that I started to
move towards greater and greater
abstraction and how I interact and
probably caused me not to focus too much
on the sort of westcoast optimization
program in part I also think that a lot
of those people spend so much time
optimizing themselves that they don't do
anything with the optimized machine that
they create and so there is a trade-off
and for better for worse I decided to
ignore some aspects of that to pursue
something that seemed impossible so it's
like they're constantly defragmenting
and they're not running any applications
or besides the disk optimization I
didn't say that for that's quite funny
okay do you microdose I remember you
were going to talk to Tim Ferriss about
micro dosing it was in the title but I
don't recall the topic of psychedelics
coming up about you personally no no
comment it drug right now in my mother
okay here's the here's the question with
the presumption in it what what
life-changing insight have you gotten
from psychedelics that you feel like you
couldn't have gone elsewhere the
life-changing insight that I've gotten
from psychedelics is that we should
never have created the Controlled
Substances Act in the early 1970s to go
after Blacks and Jews and that many of
the substances on that list do not
belong on that list because the twin
criteria that have to be met are that
something has a high propensity for harm
and that it has no known medical benefit
and we now know from research coming out
of Johns Hopkins and NYU and other
places friends at maps that in fact many
of the substances on the schedule one
list should not be on them do you find
that you're a fast reader no Bob I'm a
fast reader in a very strange sense
which is that I don't actually read the
books I have a different technique of
sampling information inside of books
trying to figure out where it's dense
and then drilling in where I need to
okay let's let's explore that let's
expand elaborate what do you mean let's
take take us through let's say you want
to learn about a topic some topic that
you haven't give me a topic touched on
before
particle phenomenology okay
okay now I just said a word particle
phenomenology so most people they're
like okay I don't even know what that is
now let's assume you obviously know what
those words mean so you have some
familiarity with the field what do you
what's your first step Wikipedia article
skim that then well the first thing is
what I want to know why it is that I'm
okay I care about particle phenomenology
did a professor tell me that that's
something I really need to drill down on
because I'm asking question or is this
just some words crossed my path and now
I have to find out what they meet so
depending upon what the purpose
is I probably do things slightly
different okay let's imagine that for
your theory of everything you know that
having some predictive power is useful
and you want to know well well how can i
mangle this into a form that that won't
be dismissive the usual let's just take
the sort of the particle and wave Zoo
you know you've got lots of things that
end in the word on it's protons neutrons
gluons photons electrons right and then
you've got different words like
neutrinos quarks and W and Z particles
so you've got this whole slew of words
around particles first thing I would say
is okay how do these words relate to
each other right so how long before you
figure out the basic division is bosons
versus fermions that's the most
important division in all of the
particles ooh okay I'm gonna stop you
for a second because I want to get into
some specifics so you're like alright
well there's some terminology and
they're disparate at least right now how
do I connect them do you do you do
something like the traditional madman
who writes on paper puts it on the wall
and then read strings between them or or
is it you type it or you ask well this
isn't my first this isn't my first rodeo
so I know that if I bomb it all the
stuff that is confusing me onto one
let's say white board or piece of paper
or a spreadsheet or whatever whatever it
is that there are going to be ways in
which all of those concepts relate to
each other and whatever that structure
is around the raw unstructured verbiage
has to be teased out and usually the
things that I care about are going to be
highly structured I can be the counter
example that history is not very highly
structured because it kind of unfolds
haphazardly or like the phylogenetic
tree in biology is pretty haphazard is
it unfolded just as it were
when things are highly systematized like
particle phenomenology you have to
understand when somebody says like the
word hadron where does hadron fit with
respect to the word pork or the word
boson or fermium so the next thing is
sort of the hierarchy of relationships
that are in intrinsic to assist so for
example if i was doing human physiology
bursar I was doing biology I would think
about the break up into the four layers
of anatomy physiology histology and
cytology right so think about those as
URIs I can't really talk about Anatomy
unless I'm also talking about the
function which is physiology and
physiology really depends on tissues so
that would be histology and tissues are
made up of cells so that would be
psychology so I would build some sort of
dependency structure and then I would
try to remember this is the top-level
categorization so that I have a map okay
now please forgive me if it's getting
tedious I'm getting too much of the
details well do you say Matt are you
writing it down or are you still keeping
it in your head or are you just reading
this I'm in flow
so maybe I'm dancing around next to a
whiteboard and I'm recording things and
I'm writing things in spreadsheets I'm
just trying to get the structure because
initially I'm always astounded at how
the the simplifying is tend to be hidden
from view until very late in the game
with most pedagogy I think because if we
give them to people up front they will
learn too quickly and teacher will hat
will be out of a job that's interesting
okay so you think there's a nefarious
reason the selfishness of the depths of
the self press availability taught
against us all which withhold the simple
diagrams that would keep us much less
confused you also mention and I'm
slightly kidding
but yeah yeah there's something to it
are you dyslexic
I've been told I'm Dyslexic of course
dyslexia is itself not always a well
understood clustered of disparate
phenomena certainly I have learning
differences from the average human yeah
okay whatever you think well some of
them are none of your business and
others of them have to do with symbols
are very cumbersome to keep straight and
they dance around too much so that it's
hard to learn through symbolic channel
okay now when I hear that and I hear
that coming from a mathematician that
strikes me as odd because math is a
tremendously symbolic so how do how do
you overcome the giant pain and then
it's 8:00 in the neck it's a real
problem right all right okay but at the
same time it doesn't seem like you took
longer than the average person to
formulate your PhD or to study you
graduated pretty much at this plus or
minus one year that the my PhD did take
longer because it you know I started
when I was 19 with the master's degree
so effectively you know function okay
okay okay yeah but you started in
nineteen with a master's degree
many people are entering university 18
no but I've heard of them from a
different point Kurt people have a very
simplistic idea okay you were really
good at math or you were really bad at
math well both of those things are true
you know if you look at Ray Charles
would you say he's good at music or bad
at his I would say I'm not sure who Ray
Charles is I'm specific animation okay
yeah it was a blind sort of right there
is a mute there's a document a
non-player okay and the next
would be after saying well he was
obviously very good at music I would
have asked you how was he at reading
music and you would have said well he
was blind of course he wasn't reading
right great he's both good and bad as a
musician if part of being a musician to
you is reading music mm-hmm um since the
same thing is true in mathematics for
those of us who are symbolically
challenged hmm okay so there's different
facets of physics and mathematics is
there one in particular about physics
that you find hard to grok or to
understand or to comprehend is there one
one so for example in math there is the
understanding of the formula which I
imagine comes to you fairly easily and
then there's the writing it though it's
those explicit explication of it out
into a formula so that is symbolic and
that one I imagine is tricky for you now
physics has different components like
there's the formula
there's the understanding as well and
there's probably three more or maybe a
hundred more what do you what do you
particularly find difficult in physics
the pedagogy is terrible
so people yuning discriminate between
closely related concepts they
they'll talk about a classical object
and a quantum problem without explaining
why they're allowed to have a classical
version of let's say the slit in the
double slit experiment but a quantum
version of the electron that supposedly
is going through both slits at the same
time and then you know you ask the
question well you know might it be the
problem that you haven't defined what an
observer is you haven't said how you
have a detector that is itself quantum
mechanical you're never quite sure with
the physicists whether they are
simplifying things in a way that is not
destructive of the truth or whether they
are actually playing with sleight of
hand
so I think physics is just they don't
think as cleanly
as mathematicians but the upside of that
is is that that non cleanliness means
that they can do things no other
community can do because they've
hybridized the purity of mathematics
with the dirt and grit of experiment
and when you're thinking do you tend to
you wrote plenty by the way I was
looking through your edge pages as well
as your papers somewhere all in
economics it is it's fairly lengthy yet
you consider yourself to have an impart
dyslexia do do you write in order to
think or do you think aloud do you think
while conversing do you think while
walking yeah but I also for example
calculate inside of a typesetting
program which is unheard of okay yeah
what do you what do you mean wire I
require the rigor of a program called
late a core law tech in order to keep my
symbols from dropping a minus sign or
running off the edge of the page so I
actually use typesetting as the
environment in which I calculate as a
crutch no when you came up with your
theory of everything let me just
actually say one other thing since
you're palling at this issue
I don't know anybody at all who is in my
situation in math and physics that is I
never met somebody with my learning
issues who refused to accept that that
they couldn't do this right because the
strong indication that I have by the
time I was leaving high school with the
b-minus in mathematics was that this was
not something I was supposed to go into
and I couldn't imagine that if the
secrets of the universe were written in
this language that anyone should be
fenced out of it because their learning
process was different from others there
have been blind mathematicians there
have been met one of the greatest is but
I never encountered any one one
one-on-one face-to-face personally who
had a significant symbolic challenge
because our language is so focused on
symbolic expression you mentioned one
time about you would take anyone
being classified as having a learning
disability and show them why they either
don't have one or you have a teaching
disability let's be very clear
there are a set of learning disabilities
which are actually not learning
disabilities and then there are things
like you know the person didn't get
enough oxygen in the birth canal and
their brain never recovered that's not
what I'm saying I'm saying that there
are certain learning disabilities in the
parlance of educators that are simply
misdiagnosed superpowers with the
deficit that pays for right is to choose
my learning disabled mutant so I'll take
that group of people over standard
learners any day you just have to change
education so that it doesn't consign the
dummy pile I imagine
painful for you to understand your own
learning disability because you're just
having trouble you don't know why you're
having such such a hard time now let's
see there are other people who have
similar maybe not similar just learning
disabilities but learning disabilities
in general or in the way that you just
define them how what advice do you have
so that they can uncover what's holding
them back because it could be a myriad
of items well first thing is is that
recognize that your performance is a
hybrid of your abilities and your
teachers abilities and that you are
going to pay the price if your teacher
cannot find abilities and just uses what
they use on every other neurotypical
student so first of all stop stop
sniveling stop saying you're bad at math
stop saying you can't do this stop
listening to your teacher stop reading
your report card recognize that none of
that actually matters for you because
it's predicated on an idea that I mean
let's imagine
example that you're in Intuit in the
north of Alaska okay should you feel bad
that you're not going to win the Boston
Marathon because the people who win that
are in general East Africans who are the
world champions of radiating heat
whereas you are the world champion of
retaining Heat because of the
differences in your environment so
you're gonna be maximally bad at
marathon running because you're very
well adapted to live in the hole now my
people stop feeling bad that you're not
the symbolic King you know solving it
complicated integrals through lots of
you know mathematical trickery instead
focus on what you're good what you're
good at which is that probably speaking
your conceptually much more advanced as
you're symbolically [ __ ] so it's
very bad for me to give advice because I
tend to tell people to stop listening to
their teachers get a backbone become
more arrogant more self-possessed learn
to build yourself up and then people
will say oh my god you're going to
encourage the dunning-kruger effect well
you know that may be true that may be
into down what I'm saying but let me say
the upside
you're gonna consign a bunch of super
Minds to the dummy pile because you
don't even understand that they can't
perform on the tests for the same reason
that one person might taste cilantro is
a beautiful spice and the other might
taste it as a bar of soap because of a
genetic predisposition we are all
different and it is not the role of
school to tell the super learners who
have my profile that they're idiots it's
much better to tell the teachers that
they may be idiots for not recognizing
they have a different population that
they're mangling okay right here you
have your own point of view and almost
every single almost invariably when
someone asks you a question one that you
haven't been posed before I assume EULA
I assume you happen it's novel to you
you will come back in about five seconds
with an interesting and different answer
I'm not always that it's cogent which is
difficult because you can string
together a sentence and not have it go
here now
that come from having an articulated
worldview I don't want that but I don't
mean to keep singing your praises but at
some point I'll insult you I'll figure
it out
but do you it does it come from were you
able to have such quick responses and
unique responses when you were 25 or
when you were 30 doesn't just come with
age if you know some I've pretty much
been the same guy since my 20s but
nobody was listening to me and my planet
okay and that came from life experience
how do you know you how do you tell
someone to think originally I see you as
an original thinker and that doesn't
mean you're correct but obviously I'm
biased I good and I don't want to give
away my biases but but I tremendously
like you and I'm curious how is it bit
someone else can what advice do you have
for someone else to be able to
articulate their own point of view well
okay so let me this is a super dangerous
question if you're really interested
I'll give you a real answer every single
person walks through their day seeing
that they're told aren't there or they
fail to see things that they're told are
there and they learn to silence their
own voice we all have this voice that is
not the voice that is received through
the television the radio podcasts
newspapers websites and we learn to
spell to ourself
now that process
is a very dangerous one to undo because
what you'll notice is that every time
you ask me a question where I don't have
a standard take potentially somebody's
gonna get really angry about it whatever
whatever it isn't that I'm saying like
you know what we were just talking about
it when I just said that many teachers
have teaching disabilities that they
pawn off on students learning
disabilities we imagine you know an
article in a newspaper called American
educator like today Weinstein continued
his tirade against the teaching like
somebody's always gonna get angry that
it's a strictly a function of courage or
did you build this up what I'm saying is
you you could say something you know
might be taken out of proportion just
like Jordan Peterson is at some point
you just you just stopped caring you
mentioned well I'm posed the same way
since I was 20 I imagine that you would
be more hard skinned as you get older
thick skinned I don't know everything
still hurts you know you're never gonna
be accepted when you give up on being
accepted you know that you're never
going home so I guess what I would I
would say to people is single one of us
has a lot of ideas and opinions that
we've never shared and you'll find this
out because when I say things somebody
will say to me oh my god you're the only
other person I've ever heard think this
nobody's ever said it out loud until now
they say oh that's interesting you had
that observation and it just didn't come
out of your mouth because you were
terrified as to what it might do someone
accused you recently on your Q&A I was
just watching some of your Instagram q
and A's and they said I'm just gonna
read you a comment and I want to know
what you would say to it hey I can't
find it right now but it was essentially
calling you an alarmist for using the
term Marxist and Maoist to talk about
those on the extreme left and what's
going on currently no no to those who
are uninitiated why why is calling them
a Maoist or Marxist an understand or an
overseen or precisely correct
what why is calling a Marxist a Marxist
I don't understand the question they
would say that what's happening right
now with black lives matters I mean let
me pull it let me get to the exact quote
someone ranted it was I don't have it I
paraphrase if someone was ranting about
you meant you talking about the current
state of affairs and it being akin to
Marxism or maoism let's remove Marxism
because some people will say I am a
Marxist and you can always write those I
mean isn't that how is that not an
accurate statement okay all right all
right
in other words you have this woman
patrisse cullors right who's a founder
of black lives matter describing herself
as a trained Marxist and her fellow
co-founders trained Marxist
so I just I guess I'm bewildered how am
i an alarmist four-lane self-described
again this so let's go back to this is
in part my frustration with your
questions
there's nothing original that I'm doing
in calling somebody who self describes
them as a Marxist a Marxist and then the
fact that I can be called out for
listening to the founders self
description like I I just don't
understand what planet I'm on am I on a
planet that faults me for being an
attentive listener why do you think
people why do you think people do is it
because they don't want to they don't
want to think it's difficult or they
have an ideology and they see an attack
so they preserve it like what is
motivating the people on Saints
resentment in Larnaca Zingerman's we're
losing our mind collectively we are in a
process of mass insanity right we've
been through these before and you know
I'm choosing not to go along with an
insanity and that generates epithets but
please don't tell me that the inmates
have once again told me that I'm crazy
because I know that that's what they
will say their inmates they're nuts
well you know going back this is this is
a reject for clarification on this why
am i answering a question about being an
alarmist who is fetch I mean like I've
just given you the name of a person who
founded black lives matter co-founded
and self describes as a Marxist trained
Marxist whatever that means not my words
and now I'm fighting the question if I'm
an alarmist I'm gonna just do something
that I like to do which is I don't like
these questions these are a legal
question I'm an accurate person whoever
made that claim is an inaccurate person
and you don't privilege inaccurate
people with the idea that we have to
answer they're inaccurate question it's
just it's a stupid exercise right
telling you before one of the reasons
why I think the radical after extreme
left or whatever you want to call them
is pestilential is because it takes
seconds to install is like what we're in
my analogy before and and days or hours
at least to unpack do you what what
avenues when you were going this is a
discursive jump but what avenues did you
explore for your theory of everything
that didn't work I mean a million what
my earliest ideas was that we should
look towards exceptional algebra to hear
it rate Jared the smaller category of
candidate theories and the natural
objects to look at in that world or two
objects plug an e 8 together with
something called the exceptional Jordan
algebra
and
you know I thought that was in Garrett
Lisi later came along and made a theory
around EA which there were certain
problems effectively it wasn't large
enough Garrett was insightful where most
people did not understand that EA tis
about a principle called tri ality
neutrality theoretically had the
possibility of weaving together the
three copies of matter that we find
known as the three families but there
actually isn't enough room inside of EA
to do this little maneuver and it's also
the case that if you used eh which is
this 248 dimensional set of symmetries
you run into a different problem which
is that you're bosons and fermions are
difficult to treat in different ways yet
they have to have different quantization
so that's an example of an avenue that I
don't see how to fix or how to solve and
probably isn't correct but that's
something I abandoned right what else if
you have to give one more just because
that one's fairly familiar people know
when some people know about e8 and I'm
curious what was what what were you
mulling over what do you mean
what were you thinking about when it
comes to theories of everything okay I
want to come up with my all so it
doesn't start with this question I want
to come up with my own theory of
everything where does it just start with
the frustration that that there doesn't
exist one well no I think it comes up it
comes from the idea that you first one
what theories exists you're not
necessarily focused on the theory of
everything you shouldn't be you should
be focused on knowing what time it is in
human history so this is one of my
Miller Ising yourself with the landscape
pardon me
so familiarizing yourself with what's
out there in the physics well there's
that but there's also the question of
you know what would Newton have done if
Newton had lived in Einstein's time we
don't know you have to understand this
weird question what time is it because
the only breakthroughs you can make are
the breakthroughs that are available to
you from more time so you know could
Galilei have landed a probe on the
surface of Titan no he wasn't in a
position to do it doesn't matter how
brilliant he is so I happen to think
that this time is the first time that it
is barely possible to get to a theory of
everything and you know that itself
isn't clear but that's part of my
determination my determination is that
we actually at least as of 19 75 or 76
were within striking distance of
finishing the whole thing off the only
problem is is that the last move is the
hardest move of all and so my take is is
that by 1975 we were in reach but the
last move is not as the earlier moves
you know there's I'm sure you're aware
Freeman Dyson and Hawking both thought
that girdles and completeness theorem
had something to say about a fundamental
theory of everything that is to say that
it excludes it or potentially exclusive
do you do you see girls incompleteness
theorem says as having anything to do
with physical theories
so being hosta thought that doesn't
think so for example so there's well it
depends what you mean I mean I guess the
way I would read it is the following
what is the theory of everything that's
something we haven't even discussed and
I don't even know that you and I agree
on a theory of everything so let me ask
you what is the theory of everything to
you well I'll tell you what what
you think and then I'll tell you what I
what I think so great I believe I heard
you describe it as a theory in which
we're no longer looking for mathematical
improvements though it leaves open the
door for religious theological
philosophy philosophical progress
however one way to define progress okay
it's pretty close okay pretty close
pretty good love it and then for me it
would be similar except I'm interested
in consciousness as well now most
physicists I'm not even sure if it's
include yourself but most physicists
believe that consciousness is a an
emergent phenomenon from fundamentally
material a material substrate and I'm
unconvinced it might be
I'm just unconvinced and I would like
there to be an explanation of
consciousness or more of an a see you
could either you can have a quantum
gravity so you can have you can unify
them gr and QM but that to me isn't in
and of itself a theory of everything I
would like more explanation so why is
there dark matter what is dark energy
why are the fundamental constants the
way they are and maybe that's asking too
much maybe it's like lisa lee smolin
where to cut the constants of all of
them they change within black holes
still that's an explanation
more interested in I see it as broader
than most people conceptualize theories
of everything I take the word everything
in other words I take the word
everything very seriously
I think that's a mistake please expand
well I give an analogy that I I'm
partial to which is a theory of
everything is an attempt to look at
chess games being played and to learn
the complete set of rules of all chess
game it is not a theory of how to play
chess well and what can be done inside
the game of chess
okay so when you're trying to come up
with a theory of everything it's really
very restricted you're trying to come up
with what is the natural mathematical
description all of the rules that
generate the universe that we see okay
the consequences of those sure sure
let's take this analogy a bit more a bit
farther then there's the question of why
are the rules the way they are why are
there pieces at all why these pieces are
those not questions that you think a
theory of everything should answer
there's rules and why the rules well
look my standard gambit which nobody
ever picks up on is the theory of
everything is effectively a newspaper
story with six questions where and when
who and what how and why where and when
is obviously space and time which tells
you it's the arena in which things are
taking place but who in the what is like
the equipment and the players so I would
say that I'm gonna make the players into
the fermions the matter and the
equipment into the bosons the force okay
we've got now four of your six questions
and then your last two or how and why
I'm gonna say how is the equations and
why Lagrangian that generates the
equation now that means that if you
don't know anything about physics you
can remember oh that guy on the internet
said where and when who and what how and
why and that that's what constitutes a
physical theory so I would say that
that's what I'm responsible for when I'm
trying to give you idiot an
understanding of where all of this comes
from are you ever interested in how is
it that the how is it that an electron
knows what to do how is it that it
follows the laws at all do you ever
think about that cuz that that could
blow someone's mind if you just keep
thinking about that or maybe it doesn't
maybe ever reason why it shouldn't blow
your mind well it's not how I
it I mean the key point is let's just
follow my my newspaper story once you've
defined as being wise the lagrangean why
not ask the Bible a Gandhian why is
there any Lagrangian or why why is the
Lagrangian the way of solving the
equations of motion so why do LeBron
turn white and how does it even follow
the Lagrangian like how does it go about
following the rules
these may be foolish questions and I
apologize it pleases it and forgive my
my naivety well what we believe is that
the electron if you will constitutes a
kind of a wave in a wave taking place
over the arena which is the who which is
the where and the when
that is space-time it is part of the who
because it's a player it's part of the
matter which corresponds to a wave and
you ask to have to ask all waves live in
a medium what medium does the electron
wave live within that medium is called a
fiber bundle and it states a vector mu
so now you've got a question okay I've
got a vector bundle and I've got a wave
now how does it know how to behave well
that question is implicitly to a
physicist
what differential equation does it obey
now a differential equation is something
that allows us to say how fast it's
moving in time and in space right how
does it propagate across the where and
the win well that has to involve rates
of change which involve derivatives
that's why it's a partial differential
equation but how do you take a
derivative of this crazy gadget which is
a wave in a vector bundle now here's the
weird thing the photon is effectively
the instruction for building a
derivative to govern the electron and we
don't say that I don't know why we don't
say that but a photon is closely
associated with the derivative operator
on the electron which is effectively a
function we call it a section the garden
variety would be a function
okay that's really cool now I've got a
derivative which is determined by the
photon differentiating a function which
is representing the electron which has
not pushed out to the general public and
furthermore that derivative has a weird
property which is that what we would say
to our calculus students is that
normally we lie to you and tell you that
mixed partial derivatives commute
Ferengi ate a quantity in the X
direction and follow that by
differentiating the Y or I can start
with the Y Direction following it by
differentiating the X Direction we claim
that those two represent the same
quantity well when you have the photon
in play they don't so you say okay well
two objects that I thought were equal
are no longer equal so now you say I
want to measure the failure of my
calculus class to prepare me for this so
I'm going to take the difference between
the two quantities that I thought were
always that are turn out not to be
well that means is the electromagnetic
field so the electromagnetic field that
we perceive is the amount of lying that
takes place when we attempt to apply the
rule that mixed partials commute when in
fact in grown-up mathematics they do not
ok well that allows the electron to
influence the photon so the function is
influencing the derivative and the
derivative is feeding back on the
function so now you've got this great
situation in which the electron and the
photon are having a conversation with
each other and changing each other's
behavior now what's the name of that
conversation
well it's called quantum electrodynamics
or quantum field theory
that's an amazing story and we don't
tell it like this and I don't know why
we don't tell it like this right
like it'll air any part of you that that
wants to write a book almost like
finding the defining lectures of physics
in his way all right
why find like listen to an internet
gadfly a non physicist with a supposed
theory of everything let's just first of
all make contact with the fact that if
there are physicists in your audience
they're getting angry saying understand
normally normally these guys are cranks
this guy sounds like he's not a full
crank I recognize a lot of what he's
saying but he's acting incredibly
irresponsibly so I might be very
interested in writing that book once the
theory is understood and accepted but
let's be clear I am acting as an
imposter I'm not a physicist I've taken
I think one semester of mechanics
I haven't taken quantum theory I haven't
taken electromagnetism I haven't taken
the standard sequence I haven't even
taken the full mechanics so whatever
you're looking at and whatever you're
talking to me about we just just put a
warning label for the benefit of our
friends in the physics community but
this is a totally unauthorized
conversation now the fact that I think
that they're falling down on the job
because they didn't tell you that the
photon was part of a derivative and that
they didn't define the electromagnetic
field strength as volt VM lying about
mixed partials and they haven't really
teased out the fact that theoretical
physics is a newspaper story and most of
their readers don't really know what a
Lagrangian is and they spend all their
time on the double slit experiment and
the entanglement in many worlds other
time wasting activities you know I have
a very deep disagreement with the
physics community about what they're
pushing out to the lay community that
they expect to support the physics in
them I think but a terrible
and so in part they should be pissed off
that I'm calling them bad exponents of
their field and that they have failed to
advance their field in 50 years and they
should say that I'm an imposter
but at the end of that day the key
question is is anybody going to move
this field forward and I'm certainly
going to try my hand at it you know I
see the vitriol thrown at you
from the physics community as akin to
the word cultural appropriation and let
me just explain my analogy here I'm just
gonna read because I have some notes
here so you mentioned that physics
businesses should be thanking you
because you put out intellectual novel
novelties to the public in the form of
offer your graduates did I say that the
physicist should be thanking me just now
not now but on on Bryan Keating's
podcast yeah okay just let me just let
me finish let me think elect me after
because you put out curiosities such as
vibrations yet physicists at least the
popular ones tend to not acknowledge the
the good that you're doing for the
physics community by by getting people
interested in physics and it could be
potentially out of spite now I'm
wondering if there's a parallel between
this and emergence of the term cultural
appropriation I was like why am i well I
think the now G is is befitting that
there's some group say black people or
brown people and they weren't able to
get success in some market for whatever
reason for it perhaps predominately
racism in this case and so they feel
like they have to demean themselves by
playing to the lowest common denominator
for the most part and then some outsider
comes usually white in their estimation
it could be Elvis or could be Eminem and
takes their dance moves or accents and
makes it palatable to a larger audience
now when I think about this part of me
says that this should be a move for
celebration because it allows the
consumption of of previously niche and
and black or minority areas for the
wider audience like rap music now white
people up rap music because of Eminem
and so in a sense it should be it should
be thought of thought of as a boon but
and perhaps I'm going out on a limb it's
not because of perhaps deep seeded
hatred that someone else was successful
in domain that they tried to be
successful in which makes them envious
and so they come up with this
intellectual justification in the form
of a construct like
cultural appropriation now do you see
the same phenomenon happening right now
to you worth you promulgating science
particularly math physics and ideas from
economics into the broader public sphere
when physicists have been twiddling
their you're a real troublemaker career
this is very interesting
okay there and and they're parroting the
same over trod and trite Schrodinger's
cat twin paradox all right do you want
to really get into this thing like
digging this yeah yeah let's go all
right so who is Otis blackwell I don't
know that's the problem you'd mentioned
Elvis but you don't even know the name
Oh dis Blackwell and Otis army
in large measure made Elvis Presley not
single-handedly but he is one of the
people who wrote the songs and sang the
songs that Elvis Presley made famous so
you know this is a problem that I talked
about on my podcast with Stephon
Alexander but in the initial
introductory essay which was coming to
understand that there were three names
that I kept finding on all the rock and
roll that I loved McKinley Morganfield
Dixon and Ellis McDaniel who these guys
I didn't know so I had to find out and
turned out that McKinley Morganfield was
Muddy Waters W Dixon was Willie Dixon
the great blues writer from Chicago and
Ellis McDaniel was a guy named Bo
Diddley the idea that a lot of these
cats never got their due and that other
people were less talented got richly
rewarded for the work that they had done
is part of a problem I don't think
that's the situation in physics I don't
think you know if you look at Elvis
Presley go look at the video for
jailhouse rock and tell me that guy
wasn't an unbelievable genius on top of
Otis blackwell you Otis Blackwell may
have been a genius for writing the songs
and all this Presley was a different
genius on top of that team that's not
the same thing
well something Bobby Darin version of
what did I say which happens to be
palatal it's not near
is frightening is when Ray Charles sings
a proper that situation is different
than saying look I don't even know what
you guys are doing you claim to be high
energy physicist to spend your time
talking about things that have nothing
to do with high energy physics you're
talking about khalaby Yau manifolds and
worlds that we will never visit because
they don't actually exist because you
ran out of ways to attack the problems
which you're specifically employed to
try to solve that's a very different
situation
and I do want to help that community
because I just don't find that that
community understands how much its
elders have run it into the ground
I mean marvel at the old h-bomb footage
and recognize what theoretical physics
is capable I mean you can't ignore it as
being a highly capable subject
right now we've failed to make progress
and so long people don't even remember
what they're doing it were they've never
seen a breakthrough in their lifetime
only the really old people have seen the
breakthroughs it's a lot like the only
people have ever walked in the moon on
the moon or you know in their 70s or 80s
and higher there's something about the
idea that no young person has succeeded
now is your art of motivation is
entirely altruistic I say that no no no
absolutely they're not entirely out I
think that I can buy much more cocaine
if I actually win a Nobel Prize than
without what are you asking me Kurt I'll
tell you because for me I I I take a
step back when I say that I'm trying to
help the world I'm trying to move the
world forward cuz I find myself saying
that a lot especially to myself and as I
studied more psychoanalysis I realized
well there's much more deep-seated envy
and hatred and callousness associated
with my motivations then then I let on
so for doing me both brother so I'll
give you an example when I was young
fairly young I heard about the Riemann
hypothesis and I was like I'm gonna
prove that and now part of me would say
I'm gonna prove that because that would
be great for the mathematical community
but the other part is that maybe I want
more attention and I want people to
recognize me as someone who can be on
their level of intellectual prowess yeah
and and so I'm curious and this snot
that's not a gotcha question at all and
I'm curious what you've well you see
your non benevolent reasons for pursuing
a theory of everything it's an
interesting in bizarre
questions is turning out to be one hell
of an interview I guess the way I look
at it is you have to look at my behavior
if I've been playing with this theory
since 1980 83 84 and I really didn't
come through to talk about it with the
world until I guess 2013 at Oxford I
would not say that wanting to be
recognized was very high on my list in
fact I don't really like it it's fun to
get the affirmation people tell you
great work and oh my god I can't believe
I'm meeting you there's a very quick
buzz that very quickly fades off with
that you lose your privacy you have to
deal with very angry people who are very
often miss portraying you sometimes they
have ways to do it at scale I don't love
this party
I am at my happiest when I'm working
completely alone on something that
nobody even knows that I'm working so
that's a very awkward thing for me to
deal with which is that as soon as you
come out and you say that you've been
working on something in my case it took
my friend Marcus - so joy more or less
telling me you don't have a right to sit
on top of the city so I don't think my
motivations are very different than my
motivations for playing the piano I
don't think I've ever performed playing
the piano in public I guarantee you that
if you put me on a desert island with
the tune piano and no one to pick me up
for five years I'd be a piano every day
simply for my own reasons and I think
it's the same thing as the physics now
if someone asked me for like insight
into my character yeah there's a
delusional aspect to my character
you mean the same if everything you have
to be deluded and another megalomaniacal
really
why do you say meg lemon I'm
I think I'm extremely overconfident and
that I feel like I can accomplish
virtually any task that's not physical
when I say physical I mean I don't I
don't think I can run that quickly nor
lift too heavy a weight but but I was
but it's rare for me to find something
that that's outside of my skull it's
actually no no it takes a little 7 times
29 great ok no just say that look the
situation is I don't think it's
megalomaniacal I think it's delusional I
think that there is a delusion and the
key question is can you pay back the the
cost of the delusion is the delusion
actually buy you something I'm sure that
Shackleton was delusional when he said
that he would rescue his men
but he did rescue his men but he had no
reason to think that he could pull it
off so you had his you have to be crazy
enough to think that you can in order
for you to attempt it yeah and I have I
have a saying which is you have to be
crazy enough to Stu dumb enough to get
in and smart enough to get out so you
have to be dumb enough to constrain
yourself in a burning building you know
with no exit and then you have to be
smart enough to figure out a way out of
the puzzle Eric how did you see that
something was going on with the nf NSF
how are you smart enough to figure it
out I'm not saying that you're not smart
I mean like how did you notice that well
what red flags were there and then what
led you down that route does someone say
by the way look up this paper well first
of all you should let people know what
you you just changed context radically
so you should introduce what you're
talking the National Science Foundation
I believe in the 1980s said that there
will be a shortage of of people
interested in stem where people getting
degrees in stem and that's going to be
deleterious for the United States and so
we need to increase the supply of people
coming into the STEM fields and one of
the ways we can do that is by allowing
it's being moral acts on our immigration
policy now that seems to have been
falsely constructed by the NSF for some
other purpose which I would like to get
into because I maybe I'm too foolish but
I wasn't able to figure that out from
the article like what was their actual
motivation was it money was it okay we
can get into that and it has and it has
had in the short-term negative effects
that is an oversupply of the market and
a lessening of the salaries for people
who are PhDs postdocs and lessening of
opportunities for them even though it
was said to be salutary on the whole now
I hope that I'm summarizing that
correctly and please correct me if I'm
wrong well what I noticed was that
institutions were obviously lying
remember that shaggy song it wasn't me
right so you know just just shaggy
instructs when you get caught red-handed
you should just hate it wasn't me
by the way Chuck Berry also wrote a
great song it wasn't me I would check
out George Thorogood
version of every month footnote footnote
um I thought it was very clear that the
National Science Foundation was too
smart to be saying things that were too
dumb and there are no labor shortages
long-term labor shortages in market
economies that is that is a feature of a
centrally planned economy but because
the wage level is intended to rise based
on this claim me one of the great things
about being part of the capitalist
society is recognizing that labor
shortages don't exist in fact labor
shortages are the misconstrue l' of wage
pressure which is exactly what was
needed to make sure that we had a more
equal society now during the 80s when
people started talking about the only
thing that makes a more equal society as
being a problem I thought wow you're
talking about labor shortages in a
market economy clearly you're trying to
pick someone's pocket why are you
putting that a great thora thing and
just as an aside to the people listening
if it sits it would have been good for
the minorities and for and for women had
had the immigration policy has not been
instantiated the way they were oh my god
would it have been amazing employers
would have had to work so much harder
they would have had to put so much more
money into time and for training and
recruiting from non-traditional pools of
talent it would have been amazing for
young women who want to have a few
children and want to be able to
negotiate their ability to be serious
academics while taking you know five to
10 to 15 years to raise their their kids
would be terrific
you know you're talking about mutual
contact of ours Stephane Alexander
you know growing up as the son of the
cab driver in the Bronx coming from a
treated Trinidadian background one of
the only black physicists at the top of
the game
how much greater would it have been if
there were a recruiters coming to
Steph's high school and his his milieu
and saying hey how do we get you kids
interested introduced to mathematical
physics at the highest level it is a
complete tragedy that we allowed
ourselves to be bamboozled this goes
back to an earlier question of yours
Kurt you asked the question of how do I
always have a different take on
everything how could all of the world's
smart people agree on labor shortages in
a market economy with nobody saying this
is total [ __ ] almost there's two
there's two claim to me there one that
they all agree and one that they don't
speak up and I would say it's the latter
they don't speak up they don't
necessarily agree okay well what does it
tell you when everyone is silent right
so that is a form of agreement I agree
with you that it's you know it's very
often by omission right every economist
knows why you don't have labor shortages
in a market economy and yet they remain
mute because they know who their real
bosses are why did the National Science
Foundation do what they did
money well Reagan I believe appointed
somebody for the first time came from
industry rather than from academics to
head the NSF which was Erich Bois
believed he was hired from IBM and he
had one of these kind of corporate
mindsets which is okay we were facing a
problem people there was a huge bulge of
hires during 60s we had a baby boom and
now we're gonna be facing a demographic
short shortfall so we don't want to have
to pay higher prices for all of the
technical talent what do we do so it's
like that you know it's like the AGI
paperclip machine somebody sets up a
problem that says we don't want to have
to
an inflated cost for technical talent
the first answer is you don't get to do
that the second answer is you don't get
to do that you dick like don't be a
complete [ __ ] and restructure the
labor market around scientists the needs
of scientific employers you just don't
have those rights yet that was the
charge and when he did do that got a
group called the policy research and
analysis division of the National
Science Foundation to do an economic
study about the wages now the problem is
is that you're not allowed to do this
you're not allowed to go after the wages
of scientists as the National Science
Foundation it's like you you know you
you wanted to know who should mind the
henhouse and so you find the best fox
that you can find to guard the henhouse
and to learn how to manage it the Fox
sets itself you know a task which is how
do we make sure that the chickens are
lined up in an orderly fashion and as
far as I from your article another
aspect that wasn't too great about the
PRA was that they didn't consult with
economists themselves they had their own
team which weren't which already had a
conclusion that they wanted to prove and
it was seriously they did it they had
economists they had their own economists
their economists were very competent
they were not incompetent the problem
was they weren't supposed to be trying
to figure out how to screw over American
technical talent at the bargaining table
for salary negotiations that's an
illegal and/or an immoral thing to do
nobody's gonna support that how do we
figure out how to screw over our own
technical talent can you imagine putting
that in front of the American people
America's technical employers need to
screw over the next generation how do we
lure unsuspecting kids with very high
abilities into a and decimate their
abilities to bargain back bargain
because that's what they were doing all
right
so what they had to do now now that
they'd studied the wage they had to come
up with an argument that didn't involve
wages because no one was going to
support the idea of screwing oversight
right right right
so now they said if we subtract off the
demand curves for labor and only talk
about the supply curbs then we can't
cross supply and demand and have people
ask us about wages so we're going to
take the economic analysis which is in
fact competence and we're going to turn
it into incompetence demographic
analysis by subtracting the demand
curves that we have in our own internal
studies and then we're going to push out
some fake stuff for the public this is
the beginning of fake news coming out of
the National Science Foundation so then
they stirred up a panic which is that
we're gonna have a demographic shortfall
meaning that there's a baby bust that
follows the baby boom and we need relief
by relief what we mean is a transfer of
wealth from Americans who work to
Americans who employ Americans who work
so why we are suddenly becoming so
sympathetic with scientific employers is
beyond anyone like why are scientific
employers something that needs bleep we
don't know so what they do
they panicked the country into passing
the Immigration Act of 1990 sometimes
called a MACT 90 which had the h-1b
provision and other provisions and then
it was later found out about two years
later that they had faked this entire
analysis in hearings held before
Congress and what I did on top of that
was to find and locate the actual study
that proves that in 1986 they were doing
secret studies inside of NSF and the
National Academy of Science and
something called the government
university industry research Roundtable
and how to gut the bargaining power of
the American scientists and for that
they should be consigned to hell I mean
it's an absolutely unethical program
which was then covered up by anybody who
challenges it is a xenophobe or doesn't
believe in the best and the brightest
which is the funniest part of it all
yeah I saw a tweet that recently you
excoriated because the person said
you're a pure villain or pure evil if
you don't allow an open border
unfortunately we don't know that there's
an answer to whether or not children
should be allowed on the internet but
there are many of them unclear okay now
I don't know too much so please forgive
me I don't know too much about US law
and it seems like two years later 1992
around that time they figured out that
the NSF was lying and there was like you
said a congressional meeting about it
so that to me sounds like well it was
just a two-year program if the effects
shouldn't be felt now did it was there
any change is it more drastic now oh
they got what they wanted they changed
the law and now you have a permanent
cabal of employers who every time you
talk about decreasing their access to
visas I mean just picture
multi-billionaire employers whining
about a labor shortage in a market
economy when their workers can't put
pressure on I mean look there's
something evil about technical employers
just positively evil you know when you
talk about the transfer of wealth from
the employees to the employers you're
referring to that the salaries would
have been higher for the employees of
Americans
and so the employees didn't want to pay
more employers didn't want to pay more
and that's why they like well it's also
the case that we produce a different
style of product you know the Chinese
graduate student in the American
graduate student are coming from very
different mill use the US has been
drenched in freedom and you know even
leading Chinese people in tech will tell
me we have a culture of obedience that
stretches back thousands of years that's
not me saying that that's Chinese people
saying this
um do you want a worker who's gonna give
you lip and be in a position where they
don't have to take your crap if they
don't want to or do you wanted to deal
with somebody who's tethered to you
because of the conditions of their music
who has grown up in an authoritarian
regime who you can tell what to do I
mean I have I conducted interviews for
the American Society of cell biologists
and there were multiple biologists who
referred to the foreign workers and
students in their labs as literally
slave labor so you know you're talking
to an employer talking about their slave
labor and laughing about
I just find it astounding this seems to
be a running thread that you notice is
that people have a conclusion and then
they come up you know with a they come
up with a reason to the public to
justify some actions so that they can
have this conclusion for example it was
one one recent one it was with the masks
that we don't want hospitals to run out
of masks so let's tell people you didn't
master or ill effective but they're
worse than that but you know that in an
infected mask can get you sick right and
I see this too on the on the extreme
left so for example I was talking to
someone who is part of the social
justice studies and what tip it was I
was with my brother actually and we
talked we pointed to some breed of dog
so you know that's an intelligent breed
of dog
and then the person said that no no it's
not there's not you can't that dog is
not more intelligent that breed is not
more intelligent than any other breed
and then I was wondering like this seems
to be not a controversial statement but
then I realized well the reason why
she's saying no don't compare dog breeds
is because that if you compare dog trees
maybe what about races and then you
might be and because that's right so the
idea of being that natural selection
applies to every species other than
humans and we have it's totally
different rules it's it's
these are infantile thought patterns
right when I look at to wrap up but this
is gonna be another tangent but when I
look at some of your older videos like
from the early 2000s you're you're much
more articulate now than you were then
you're eloquent now you're poor I'm not
saying you weren't back then I'm saying
you're more now what video are you
talking
so firstly some of your early Tim
Ferriss interviews second you speaking
with Lee Lee Smolin about economic age
theory and one about economic Manhattan
Project as I believe on the perimeter
website don't know 100% sure okay well
to each his own
yeah getting older and I'm losing my
faculties no no no no I'm saying you're
better now I know that's weak okay
the area's more to do it before but okay
okay there you go right well what I want
to know is is do you did you work on
your articulation do you practice in
front of the camera turn it off watch it
and then don't release it really okay
let me improve or is it just something
that comes as a function of age then you
don't do exercises to improve no but
it's a regularise even in Korean I I
don't see the change but maybe it's
there I don't know
okay you mentioned that on your recent
product on your recent podcast with Bret
that talking about free will in the
discourse discord servers you said he
said sometimes you log on you see people
talking about free will and one other
topic which I can't recall but free will
in particular is unproductive well why
why do you say that debating about free
will is unproductive well what I what I
notice is that people will have the same
conversations over and over again and if
I tuned in on one or I tune in another
I've pretty much heard all of the
arguments that are being advanced so I
believe that you have to learn to
recognize the signature of people trying
to solve a mistaken problem they're
trying to solve a problem where the
framework for solving that problem does
not yet exist okay so it's not the
problem itself it's the framework of the
problem much like the problem relative
to the framework that we're in where
people will have a conversation that
will go on for an hour before anyone
will ask the question do we even know
what we mean by free will
so I just find these conversations are
not like the conversations of you know
another topic I want to get people
interested in is that the habberman
switch pitch which is a toy bit based on
the self duality of the tetrahedron
could you build one exhibiting the
duality between the dodecahedron and
icosahedron that's a very concrete thing
that could be done somebody could
actually build a physical implementation
of this idea I'm positive that the
freewill discussion is gonna be going on
two weeks from now it's gonna sound the
same as the one this week now I couldn't
be wrong maybe somebody in some discord
chat somewhere is good and then I will
have egg on my face but I'm so unworthy
bad that I'm willing to commit to you on
this podcast that 20 years from now
we're still going to be having freewill
discussions if we don't have a more
profound theory of physic did you do you
have a personal definition of freewill
that you think is okay you mentioned
once that you like hey I do the rituals
of Judaism I don't consider myself a
practical and consider yourself a
practicing Jew but not a believing Jew
in the sense that you consciously
believe it but maybe unconsciously you
do in a Peter Sounion sense there are
behaviors our thoughts did you say Peter
sodium yes
I didn't know there was a Peter Soni and
yes I just I I like to use the word
Peter so needed since it's easier for me
okay okay well do you pray yes oh okay
that's it true now when you pray who do
you feel like your friend to if you
don't if you look Webber's around you
literally as in people oh I know you're
joking but I'm actually trying to I'm
actually curious and please forgive me
if this is too personal
no no I mean I think it has to do with
the idea that the concept of prayer is a
conserved concept in the human psyche so
you have widely separated groups who
come up on the idea of prayer and I
think it's because the human mind has an
extended phenotype if you will of
behaviors so you know we build churches
and mosques and synagogues and all sorts
of houses of worship that's part of our
extended phenotype we gather to sing do
you pray you try to what what what
tradition deed the you grow up then I
grew up in my family is Christian but
then I became an atheist as as a as a
young person after my brother told me
about quantum fluctuations because they
always been heard well how the heck
could nothing could something come from
nothing and then one time my brother was
walking with me to Blockbuster this is
always and and he mentioned yeah well
there's something called quantum
fluctuations and then I remember sitting
up in my bed and just thinking well that
doesn't have to be a reason for God so I
was an atheist and then and now I'm I'm
unsure I would say that I I hope I'm I
hope I'm religious because well we can
get into that conversation well I'm
pretty much of an atheist if you take
say the lyrics of you know Forever Young
by Bob Dylan I don't know too much of
music not a musical person I play music
but I don't listen to it yeah
starts off may God bless and keep you
always may promise to be true maybe what
what to do for others and let others do
for you may you always be courageous
stand upright and be strong and may you
stay forever young it's an absolutely
beautiful song it gets tremendous power
from the form of
right it gets tremendous power from the
form the form of a prayer okay right you
know if you think about Madonna's like a
prayer if you think about you
talked about a CDC's song you shook me
all night long which uses these four
notes yes you shook me all night long
very similar to SH - Ryan I don't know
either pain I don't I like the power of
those four notes I don't know you but I
want you to deny this is part of the
human endowment
is crazy so yeah maybe you're not gonna
go to synagogue and then you're sitting
there and you're doing what you're
singing
you shook me all night long you know and
it's erotic it's sacred it's profane
it's all of those things that animate us
in the contrast and the contradictions
and the you know the run-ins and the you
know weird juxtapositions so I think
that you have to recognize that prayer
has a function in our minds that we only
partially understand having nothing
necessarily to do with whether there's
somebody on the other end of the phone
when we place the call Eric you sing
when you're alone
yeah what are you saying and even what
I'm not but what are some of you
fortunately I have a high you know
interestingly I love nirvana so I love
Kurt Cobain and one of my other idols is
Kurt girdle and my name is Kurt and
that's just completely I wonder if
that's a correlation during its cost or
if it's just Queens you may be losing
your marbles but okay yeah so Nirvana
are Our Lady peace Alanis Morissette I
like 90s yeah well if you think about
Kurt Cobain there's something very sort
of
I
that there's something very blasphemous
and very sort of profane about his
alienation and honestly it's better when
it's animated by its relationship to
religion a little bit wait okay sorry
explain what you mean there that Kurt
Cobain's music is better when it's
animated by its relationship to religion
what do you mean
um well you know if you just take a line
like she's over bored and self-assured I
know I know the dirty work this is a
dirty word right all right look clearly
that's animated by religion you know did
somebody say damn and you have to have
your mouth washed out with soap in the
nineteen twenties I don't know so I see
so you're saying that music has made
richer when you appreciate religion
where you merchants or understand it in
the context of religion well like I was
talking about what did I say before you
know the most scandalous thing about
what did I say was the merging of
sexuality and gospel so he stopped the
middle of song and goes ah and his
backup singers going in through this
grunting ritual which is clearly
extremely sexual with the gospel feel to
it all right I can tell you that there's
nothing quite so transgressive as the
concept of sacred sexuality with the
choir so that
song has the power to shock us precisely
because a different standard was
referenced and I do think that the
tension between reason and religion and
between superstition and ritual versus
our metacognitive facility which says
why am i doing these things that's been
incredibly potent it would be very weird
to throw religion out once you realize
that it's not literally true but yet
many people do that right and that also
has the sub claim that if you don't
believe in religion as it literally is
then you're not Christian or you're not
Jewish and I I was speaking with Peter
Glenn knows who's a specialist in the
history of religion he was saying that
if you go to eat early early Christian
early Christianity early Judaism like
third century in and 300 or 200 BC as
well for Judaism that to say to think of
the Bible as literal was also a sin for
song sex could say whatever you want
these are tensions that don't get
resolved and most of the rap I think I
know I've said I know five or six rabbis
well enough to ask the question do you
believe in God none of them do
everything you standard typical trivial
sense that yeah I believe that these
stories are literally I'm curious about
your use of language sometimes even
Brett in the most recent podcast that
Eric you do use terminology that I'm
pretty sure you know that the
interlocutor is unaware of so for
example with you and Anna
you use the term expansion point to
describe the media and me as a
mathematician I know what expansion
point means but I'm pretty sure Anna
doesn't and neither and I'm pretty sure
that you know that Anna doesn't know so
I was curious why would you use that
another example was when you were being
asked about Bitcoin you said something
this is locally conserved
this is like local conservation law
something like that and I'm curious what
why do you use esoteric language now
here's some theories so someone might
say while you're trying to sound
intelligent and or another one might be
well this is how you think and you're
thinking aloud another one might be well
you're trying to provoke curiosity in
the audience well I don't want to give
you some answers but I think an
excellent job of answer here a question
I'm not interested in sounding
intelligent because that's going to cut
down on my estimation of intelligence
probably and it's going to cut down on
my listenership so to be blunt about it
just a minute just a minute
to be blunt about it I think there's a
difference which is why does this
language even exist why don't you ask
the people who live inside of every
single discipline to conduct themselves
so that if their grandmother barges in
she'll be able to follow the
conversation I don't know where that
became a good idea or a gold standard no
there's a quote of fineman's that
everybody likes to throw at you which is
you know that which I cannot create I do
not understand or another one which is
you have to you can't explain something
you know to every man and you don't
really understand it mm-hmm horseshit
nonsense we developed certain language
for a reason because it's well tailored
to what it is that we're thinking about
so what y'all let's take the case of
Bitcoin Bitcoin is frequently advertised
as digital gold but what is gold gold is
a physical element it's created from the
fusion of stars where stars collide and
that allows us to overcome certain
barriers so that the protons can fused
together all right so bold is a is
effectively based on a nucleus which is
fermionic and that fermionic nucleus is
a wave and that wave behaves in a
physical sense now what is the
quintessential issue about gold is that
it's hard to produce it's hard to faith
gold you can't just go print up a bunch
of gold because you'd like some some
gold marks so of course if you could put
water and dirt into your Smithson 5000
machine and have gold bars come out the
other side gold wouldn't work as a form
of currency r is a store of value so
what are the properties abstractly of
gold that makes it work as a store of
value well the fact that if I have a
pole bar and you do not and if I give
you the gold bar are no longer at that
is a conservation law
and the fact that I can give you a gold
bar in my backyard and nobody can stop
us from that making that transfer has to
do with the fact that it's locally
enforced I don't need to go to a central
authority permit like if I have money in
a bank account I wish to put it in your
bank account we have to involve the
banks and the transfer okay well this is
a locally enforced rule with gold
that's because gold is concerned I'm out
of gold I give up to you is the amount
of gold that you now have that I do not
now that's how I think and why I
constantly want to be referenced to some
standard whereby the source of my
thinking is covered up no effectively
the way I'm using language is a bit like
scaffolding for a building and I'm
leaving the scaffolding up so that if
you're confused by what I'm saying you
have a hope of not only saying well
that's interesting but you can also say
I wonder where he got it from oh his
language is a clue I'm gonna find out
what a conservation law so by leaving
the scaffolding up I feel like it's
actually an invitation to people who are
more interested to figure out where the
stuff comes from so if I have some
paradigm in the theory of natural and
sexual selection and I talk about it in
terms of natural and sexual selection
I'm giving you the pointer the hyper the
metadata a hyperlink to go find out
where I got my thinking from so as far
as I'm concerned I'm giving you extra
and if you're put off by that that's
really your problem not mine I guess I
started deciding that I would use my own
native language my own native language
is a version of English with a Creole or
pidgin on top of it made from the
languages of the fields that I draw from
the economics physics finance risk
computer programming music molecular
biology evolutionary theory architecture
wine whatever these things are they're
all sources of inspiration and so I
guess I actually just reject the charge
and I find it very infantile that people
imagine that it's an affectation I think
I just gave up not talking the way I
natively think so at some level you're
looking at somebody else's code and I
probably use a pastiche of different
programming languages if you will where
most people agree that they're gonna
write programming in some very
restricted set of commands and my
feeling is well your restricted set of
commands aren't sufficiently expressive
now you see I've just done it again
expressive as a concept that you would
talk about in the comparison of computer
languages but my point is that that's
the natural paradigm for me to explain
the thought do I want you said to me
earlier you asked the question how is it
that you always have sort of a
contrarian or original answer no matter
what question gets asked and in part
it's exactly this that I try to look
into all the different fields for what
they sell at and borrow whatever I can
learn from them about how to think about
various paradigms and then even to see
the same paradigms crop up in fields
that are widely separated and nobody
knows that the same way of thinking
occurs across them all I think that's
that's one of the ways that you are able
perhaps to integrate the knowledge
because one of my earlier questions that
I didn't even say was if these fields
are so variegated and they seemingly
have nothing to do with one another
although if it's a part of this world
there's some connection how is it that
you're able to keep all this knowledge
in your head because for example I took
an economics course in the university
but I forgotten most of the fundamentals
and it's I blamed that person I'm not
using the knowledge on a regular basis I
was like well does Eric uses knowledge
well how does he use it perhaps he uses
it in conversation now you're you're
you're actually giving credence to this
idea I'm gonna thought well maybe also
he uses it when he writes maybe he
writes privately and it's constructing
some theory on it so that's why I asked
you about writing some actually so this
whole conversation was and an attempt to
deconstruct deconstruct deal and I said
well I would say that I just have more
room in my brain because I've decided
not to keep track of the Kardashians